on this episode we have a ton of guests
and we go dark and we go hi everybody
this is gary vay-ner-chuk and you're
watching episode 12 of the askgaryvee
show fun fact for episode 12 the number
12 the number of the Hall of Famer Joe
Namath the greatest quarterback in New
York Jets history it's good to be back
let's get to it
Digita tasks as a freelancer should you
ever work for exposure only marry
Congrats on being the by the way the
first person to get two questions asked
on the askgaryvee show and I know I know
I me to see in the comments ever doesn't
like you haven't even answered mine yet
now you've answered marry second
question yes
she asks good questions but this
question I really want to answer because
I've been having a lot of Twitter
conversations lately and very honestly
for the basic 8 to 10 years that I've
been in the tech game meaning all these
wonderful people especially when you
think about the tech game when I first
got into it it was very save the world
and much more Zen it was less businessí
characters like me probably ruined it uh
this is a big debate this is something
that I sit on a very firm line on which
is I do think that people should do
things for free for exposure
I still do things for free and I get
very compensated for my time and my
efforts and I still do it and somebody
will say I had an easier base people
have to pay the bills but the fact that
people don't take into account that
there is strategy in doing things for
exposure that then leads a bigger money
in the future this is not about elitism
like some people jump on Twitter and say
pay the people you got to pay for the
quality of work I agree but one needs to
understand that money is not the only
way to pay giving people on that bat the
platform the exposure is an absolute
monetary way to compensate them in the
way that I define monetary listen by the
way you might fully disagree with me and
that's cuz you've gone romantic on the
issue in my POV and I respect that but I
just don't know a single per
that is deemed has achieved success
without doing a solid percentage of
things for free as a jockeying chess
move to their success so if you're
asking me the answer is yes if you don't
do it and you only pay to play I get it
and by the way it evan flows i now
respond to many of you know i cannot
speak at this event unless i get my fee
because i promised my wife I will not
travel without getting my fee because
I've got two young kids this and that
and so like it changes you know I will
not be sold by anybody that it is
inappropriate to do some spec work
because I really believe in its strategy
what's up Gary its Mitch Snyder and I've
got a question for you the company I'm
working for has a great story we're
putting up great content on all our
social channels but we're not seeing the
engagement we were hoping for is it
worth it
to promote our Facebook posts our tweets
and our LinkedIn posts in order to gain
more engagement on what we're putting
out there what do you think are they
worth it I think they're worth it now I
think they're worth it if you actually
target it properly so used promote and I
would say target meaning Twitter you can
target actual words that people are
using to get even more narrow into who
you're trying to target Facebook dark
posts we've at nausea talked over these
twelve episodes of Facebook dark posts I
do think you should target but and this
is why I turn my face to the camera
while you were asking the question my
friend you're deeming it to be great
content maybe it just isn't right and I
think that that's a dangerous thing that
a lot of people really need to figure
out which is you may feel good of how it
looks but the reason I wrote Jab Jab Jab
right hook is is a contextual a proper
does it have the right hashtags is at
linking properly you have the right
amount of length are the pictures proper
are you putting the logos in the right
spots within it please triple-check you
have to check yourself before you wreck
yourself they say and so please triple
check that you're checking all the boxes
of doing all that stuff properly number
two I do believe that if you can afford
if you're lucky enough that a lot of
people watching are lucky enough but if
you're lucky enough to have the
resources to target a segment and boost
up its awareness if that content is good
that is going to spread like fire for
you and it's going to pay much bigger
dividends long-term so I am a fan of it
Eric asks what's the last new skill you
learned as a result of taking an
interest in someone else's passion hobby
or job Eric it's a really interesting
question I'm trying to figure this out
you know one that's emerging a little
bit believe or not but I'm not going to
accept it as golf AJ has fall in love
with golf my bro and you know I don't
know if I'm picking up a skill but I
guess I am a little bit I'm out there I
didn't like thinking like should I get
into it I just can't commit to the five
hours that it takes to play and so I'm
scared people get addicted with golf so
that would have been the answer but I've
been luckily able to hold off that
insanity of the golf drug I would
probably say and this is a weird answer
I probably say respecting data uh you
know I think that I believe in targeting
and big data and all this new digital
stuff because Eric Catherine John
kassimatis when they started
vaynermedia's developers showed me the
other side of marketing which was
retargeting in CRM and all these things
and so that was probably the last skill
that I remember really picking up yeah I
would say I would say respecting data
John asks when you're in a phone what do
you do to get out of it John you've
asked a question that I've been really
excited to share with the world because
it works
it is very dark like this is dark so
like I know that most people when they
share my content say beware potty mouth
McGee
this one's beware you may be like
frightened with a little bit of like a
tear drop on your left eye left I'm
gonna tell you the truth because that
was the commitment when I decided to do
this which you know obviously I'm able
to work Steve's curing the questions but
I could always kibosh them so it's it's
when I start doing these live or when we
do live events or we take the show on
the road and it's audience participation
then it'll really be the full monty but
for now I'm answering them and I'm
answering them truthfully this is a dark
one I'm stalling because it's dark it's
it's dark when I'm in a funk I literally
close my eyes put myself into a place
where
something remarkable happens to me uh
you know you know CNN names me the
greatest man of all time you know like
like just literally like silly things
like I get on a list of being the best
entrepreneurs or or Birchbox sells for
four billion dollars and I make a lot of
money or the full extreme when I'm in my
most funk I literally try usually I do
things that are realistic and happen
within a one year window but in my
deepest funks I'll I'll project this is
harder it's a little more roleplay
because when I think about stuff that's
gonna happen intimately it feels real
but I'll dream about buying the Jets and
I'll think about those great things and
then I literally I literally make
pretend that Birchbox sells and I make
millions of millions of dollars and that
that's the phone call and the next phone
call is from my hysterical sister
telling me that my mother died in a car
accident and I really do that and I
really go there and I very like like I'm
very as you guys know me I'm an
emotional character I go there and it
really does something interesting for me
I really don't care that I made seven
million dollars if my mom died I just
really don't and I can even as I'm
telling you this right now I can feel it
I can truly feel how little I care about
that in in comparison to what I would
feel with that pain and very honestly it
just sets me straight it just reminds me
what my priorities are and it allows me
to understand that the health of my
children or my wife I mean the fear and
the the shivers I get when I think about
their passing in you know in real life
like them dying and it just sets me so
straight it just makes me realize how
non important losing that client was or
that best employee or that deal or that
opportunity passing on uber in the first
round which would have given me one
hundred million dollars in paper so they
got to go public but it's pretty damn in
there
it's something I can deal with because
the truth is it's just not what makes me
happy and more importantly I'm so happy
that everybody I love has been healthy
for so long losing grandparents early
has put me in that position so a
negative
positive and and that's what I do I go
in a very strange cocoon and make
pretend the people I love the most died
Gary B Amy s savvysexysocial.com maybe
you remember me huh
my question is I'm finding that the more
I travel more events I go to it's like
this like major intensity constant high
of meeting people and great content it's
like so insane and then I come home to
like total normalness and sometimes that
like is such a drastic change that
actually feels low when it's not
actually that low it's actually just
normal but you're just coming down from
such a consistent high of being at like
a five-day conference and it's like
crazy
how do you stay level between all these
events that you do because you actually
instill the intensity in people when you
go speaking and all that kind of stuff
I'm just trying to find some balance in
my life Gary trying to find the balance
I think you've got it I think you got it
help me out Amy you've got me pegged I
do have it I am equally as fired up
sitting by myself on a 6-hour flight in
an airplane as I am speaking front of
7,000 people being the person that is
the Puff Daddy of that event which is
the hype artists yeah yeah and so uh and
so you know I'm not sure maybe it's very
similar to the question that we just did
I do have that balance because I'm
thankful for what is in front of me I
very much live in the moment one of my
flaws and or my gifts is that I'm so
into what I'm doing of that moment that
I do forget about my family or my
responsibilities because I'm so sonde
right now I literally could care less of
what's going on with anything outside
this cube because I'm zoning in to the
askgaryvee show so I'm very all in on
what I'm doing and so when I come dydt
back from that hi first of all I'm
pretty much hi although I mean I can I
can create high from calm if I need it
because I'm hyped and excited yeah you
know I don't this is an answer that's
very difficult I wanted to show this
answer because I appreciate
because I think a lot of people think
about it but the truth is this is very
something that comes very natural to me
it's intuitive I would just ask all of
you and I talked a lot about this I
tweeted out quite a bit over the last
two weeks about my grateful kind of post
on medium
I think gratitude Amy I mean just be
grateful be grateful that you have some
downtime and it's just normal and it's
nice and you get to see your core
friends and family and be very grateful
that you're lucky enough to go to
five-day tech raves where you can like
be on that hi Duke asks what would you
say NJ has learned and applied from you
in business and would he be willing to
answer this question on the show
Duke memo alert this is the askgaryvee
show this is not the ask a JV show with
no silent E's this is my show I answer
the questions there is no AJ answering
the questions it's me I do it it's my
show take it away bro
Duke thanks so much for the question
it's a really good one and one that I
could probably spend a couple of hours
talking through but I know this show is
long enough already
trying to think through it there like I
said there's a lot to go through I think
one of the biggest things is perspective
I think that in the course of growing a
business very fast there's a lot that
gets thrown at you and there's a lot of
good and there's a lot of bad and it's
really keeping the the highs not too
high the low is not too low and really
taking a step back thinking about the
wider impact of everything that's
happening and really just not stressing
yourself out too much I think every day
goes by a lot happens but you really
just focus on what's important think
about the big picture
that's been massively beneficial for me
as we've grown the business together at
Vayner another huge one for me is just
the value of the team and HR and just
really focusing on personalizing the
experience with your staff I think you
know when focusing on HR I think there's
a temptation to be a little bit too
by-the-book you know follow a process a
handbook of how to handle reviews and
how to handle situations and we very
much take a look at every situation that
comes our way
with anyway that we work with and really
personalize that and really think about
the situation and the impact of it and
then we use a cookie cutter system I
think just really focusing on HR you
know we grew very fast at Vayner we went
through a spurt of roughly from 12
employees to 25 employees to 100 to 250
to 400 and when you're growing that fast
thing the two things I mentioned really
keeping perspective and big picture
thoughts and really making sure that
you're focusing on the team and the team
within and focusing on their growth how
they work with you how they work with
each other and those are the two biggest
things I think I've taken away from
working with Gary and having him as my
my brother my business partner in my
mentor and my best friend appreciated
Brel nice answer that is episode 12 of
the askgaryvee show this is the first
week of football there'll be a lot of
football talk the rest of the week get
ready for it Raider Nation you are going
down you keep asking questions oh wait I
was about to close but the question of
the day say little rusty from all that
kind of like that was me looking at my
tan if you're wondering what the hell
hours push of the day let's make it
football
what is your lock of the week what is
your survival pool pick your pick no
spread survival pool pick who's your
lock for this week one of the NFL season
my favorite week of the year especially
now that school's finished you keep
asking questions I'll keep trying to
answer them
you
you